uh let's go
next why don't we go to
let's go to boris from denver boris uh
what's going on in denver these days
hey dave it's just really cold oh you
know some stuff here and there but not
too much
i wanted to ask you been doing some
reading
for black history month and i was
curious
i have an answer to this and i think you
would agree with but i was thinking
these days if martin luther king was
around would the right try to smear him
as being too woke
oh my god of course oh this is wow yeah
absolutely you know now you see many
republicans now sort of slickly try to
appropriate themselves of martin luther
king and say you know we we love the
ideals of they'll list a few people
they'll be like lincoln
and reagan and martin luther king or
whatever
they they would be smearing martin
luther king as a walkster socialist and
i mean yeah without a doubt without a
doubt
yeah and the thing that really drives me
crazy is a lot of them like i've even
seen
the new governor of virginia they try to
quote him
when they pass a lot of these
anti-critical race theory bills yes as
if he as if to suggest that martin
luther king was opposed to critical race
theory and he was just like uh you know
an american loving
person who just thought oh america's is
just a little flawed but it's a
fundamentally great country and all that
but they'd ignore when he said like
america is racist and all that and one
other thing i wanted to ask about this
do you think that
could you see a future i seriously can't
see one where they will try to smear him
anyways when like his files get released
in 2027
and the fbi files show that you know
he maybe was involved with you know
there are allegations that he
uh
that he didn't uh stand up to a friend
that was like raping a woman or
something like that he was like casually
um
he was like in the room as some woman
was getting raped and he didn't do
anything about it or something like that
listen i've never heard that before so i
don't i want to be i don't know anything
about that i couldn't possibly make any
predictions about that i want to be i
just i've just not heard that i couldn't
comment on that
okay well i've i've seen there was like
a report that came out not too long
probably a few years ago yeah i saw
gavin mcginnis did on his show and even
tucker carlson tried to cover and i
think they were just trying to like i i
just felt like it was the start of what
i'd see 10 years from now the right is
going to completely portray martin
luther king as this uh bad person yep i
think i mean they'll do both things they
they will
attack martin luther king when it's
convenient and they will take credit for
martin luther king when it's convenient
and they're already kind of doing it
yeah okay last thing get off uh do you
have any plans or would you opposed to
going on back on joe rogan's podcast
i i have no i've not been invited i
would go back on anytime
okay cool i'd love to see you uh back on
there hopefully you haven't course
correct thank you i would love to do it
all right thank you so much for the call
very much appreciate it